[موسيقى]
منذ الصغر انا كان لدي رغبه ان اجيب على
اسئله
كنت
الكتابه كانت هي
هي
يعني هي الوسيله اللي من خلالها حاول ان
نجيب على هذه الاسئله لكني كلما كتبت كنت
اكتشف مقدار الجهل عندي وتتسع هذه الدائره
وكنت حقيقه يعني لدي رغبه عميقه في فهم
الخبره الانسانيه يعني هذا هذا اللي كان
يشغلني
[موسيقى]
عشان كده كان علاقتي مع الروائي نجيب
محفوظ علاقه عميقه جدا لانه هو فيلسوف
وجودي انا من وجهه نظري رواياتها كلها
نماذج للتامل الوجودي في الحياه وفي
الانسان هناك روح تسكنك كنت ابحث عنها
فعرفت ان انه درس البكالوريوس طبعا في
الفلسفه
[موسيقى]
اذكر اني التقيت باحد الاساتذه
البريطاني لكن يدرس في امريكا
فقلت له انا اريد ان ادرس الفلسفه اريد ان
ادخل في برنامج الماجستير عندكم
فقال عندنا شرط نحن لابد ان يكون لديك 12
ساعه اكاديميه لكي تقبل يعني
فقلت انا عندي حكايه دعني احكيها لك وحكيت
لحكايه الفلسفه في السعوديه واشكالاتها
فقال لك علي ان انقل حكايتك هذا لاجتماع
مجلس القسم لكي نحصل لك على استثناء
لقبولك في القسم وفعلا هذا هذا الذي حدث
فكانت طبعا تجربه جميله
[موسيقى]